welcome back to new rockstars it's me mt
and oh my god mcu brian absolutely
changed the game at the end of miss
marvel when he told ms marvel that she
was in fact a mutant in the mcu while
zuzu of course played the x-men 97 theme
song in appropriate fashion in the
background uh but while some people
might think that this might be a
retconning of kamala khan's inhuman
comic origins what if i went rogue and
said that they are not doing that what
if i went extra rogue and said that in
fact the mcu inhumans are actually
mutants
this is rogue theory the show where we
pitch the wildest theories for the nerdy
titles that we love my name is mt and
going world with me today is the only
person i want helping me set up a home
alone style trap in a public school on a
saturday it's whitney van landingham
what's going on with me yeah i was
really hoping that that was for me
okay
context for the for the viewers at home
i frantically messaged the break room
yesterday and i was like can i please
pitch a topic they had already had the
meeting it's fine i was late
please can we please do something that's
like kevin mcallister versus the dodc
who would win
and then brandon brought up that it
would be better to do the stickers yeah
you got wet bandits
versus dodc who's better at going
through the traps yes that's that is
what i want to see that's what i want to
know um that would be amazing yeah i
would love that and of course my brother
who shares the big head x gene it's the
next step in human evolution my brother
tommy beck told himself what's going on
yeah baby these guys are screaming on
this hat
it's an eight it's a size eight but it
needs to be a size eight and a half but
that's okay we'll just keep massaging it
down massaging it down yes good to be
here big head gangway it's the big head
gangway
finally the mcu's second mutant with the
power of production it's the king
himself off-screen producer brandon
what's going on brandon thank god it's
the power of production and not the
power of reproduction because i don't
need any kids
i don't want to get him out of here
i mean i've noticed
this world yeah the terror stops here
the terror ends with me
oh my god
but
speaking of genetics and all this stuff
which leads us to our first topic of
today
yeah i think that humans are just
mutants with cree influence in the mcu
all right guys so
miss marvel is officially a mutant and
of course a lot of people on the
internet are upset because you know it's
the internet that's just the home of
upset people uh but yeah they are upset
about what appears to be a massive
change to kamala khan's comic book
origins as she was originally an inhuman
in the comics of course
however despite hearing that amazing
x-men 97 jingle right after brian mayor
of the friend zone said the n-word i
don't believe it means kamala khan isn't
inhuman i just think that in humans and
mutants in the mcu could actually just
be
cousins because much like the x gene the
inhuman gene is also
a mutation and they are both mutations
of the human genome so if you take into
consideration what we know from the
marvel comics the reason why human
beings even have the inhuman gene in
their dna in the first place is because
a long time ago the cree came across
early humanity and saw that they had a
really neat genetic code given to them
courtesy of the nerdy ass celestials
running their experiments thousands of
years before the cree had arrived so my
rogue theory is that kamala khan's
mutation that uh brian o'brien found is
actually a variation of the xg mutation
an x gene that had been altered by cree
curiosity and an x gene with a giant
cree lock on it that keeps that extreme
mutation from activating unless the
inhuman terrigen mists are present
making that etch gene into a new inhuman
variation of the x gene so what do you
guys think of that really long
explanation
i completely blacked out after i heard
the words
ryan mayor of the friend zone who sent
yeah empty he's not talking to kate
bishop you don't have to be mean to this
guy okay yeah like he is not interested
whatsoever
in california so maybe i don't know i
mean well i don't know if kate bishops
in california but like maybe she's like
i don't know i just don't trust him all
right he's gonna stay away from keith
bishop that's mine i do think you're
onto something empty because i think
they they really teased the pterogenesis
like when uh when what's her face
touched the veil and both of them and
they kind of turned into rock and then
like crumbled away it reminded me so
much of pterogenesis and i was like oh
okay
this is weird it's like killing them
which we know pterogenesis does kill
mutants uh which is very interesting um
but i i like this idea that yeah they
kind of just want to blend the inhumans
and the mar and the mutants in an
interesting way
um
especially because
yeah it's just weird like go back i like
the idea that in this timeline in this
universe the cree never went to ancient
earth to mess with humans they're just
going to start messing with humans now
because they're like we need a new
weapon
and like it's
they're going to start making inhumans
now uh and they just didn't do it in the
past and they'll kind of and though
they'll maybe like pick mutants to do
the inhumans treatment too i don't know
maybe they'll they can identify that
mutation in the blood because i also
thought it was weird how comron's
crystals
you know they also looked like kind of
rocky
why is he manifesting these weird bands
like that i don't know right i don't
know i don't know i'm kind of like why
not both like why couldn't they have
also been doing it a long time ago
that's true fell off and then now
they're doing it again because they're
like oh wait that was a good idea the
old way i mean like nick fury did
mention uh splinter cell of crete that
um are on earth so like maybe that
crease splinter cell is like a little
science splinter cell that's away from
like the actual main creator that's just
like hey human beings they're weird
let's check it out
and then
and the queen the kree abandoned the
inhuman
the cree like abandoned the inhumans
project because like the wasn't it the
supreme intelligence was like oh no
these inhumans are going to kill us we
got to stop we got to back off right but
maybe i like this idea
of your like splinter cree who are like
religious fundamentalists and they're
like no no no the supreme intelligence
is wrong we gotta make the inhumans
they're they're what we need and most of
the creed does not want to and they're
like making them as as weapons could
refresh my memory here the cree start
doing the experiments because they can't
evolve naturally right they're not able
to right to evolve right that's why
they're trying to maximize a lot
different than ours yeah that's why they
start messing with things and making
different color cree and all this kind
of stuff right right okay
okay like yeah i could totally see them
just messing around with humanity
because they themselves can't evolve so
like and we know from the end of captain
marvel that the cree are so interested
in the human genome's ability to produce
super-powered people like captain marvel
right and so that's why uh running the
accusers were like oh we'll be back
we'll be back for that weapon um and
since you know captain marvel's never on
earth it's like all right let's just use
these human beings instead to make a new
captain marvel uh why not um yeah all
these aliens are always probing us why
are they always messing with us
seriously i'm done being probed enough
with the probing we've had way too much
probing content on new rock stars lately
not enough yeah too much probing yo like
there's a celestial called one egg the
prober that i was upset with not in
eternals because i need to probably uh
[Music]
[Laughter]
i already checked the toilet for snakes
every time i sit down i'm not i don't
know anything about surprises
yeah i don't need a tia
but you know what i'm saying
i know what you're saying
my god that's hilarious anyway
what do you think tommy empty you
ridiculous bastard
this is agents of shield erasure i don't
like new things i don't like change i
say put everyone through the mist and if
you survive you get kissed
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
by the science of marvel in general at
all times uh
i yeah
i'm gonna say the same thing dude yeah i
like the idea of a pre-supercell though
yeah just like doing little experiments
like they're kind of like one of those
science cults that like eventually gets
tax exemption in america as a religion
like they're like
so so i'm on board i'm on board with
decree with the korean me
uh doing me 23andmes to find out who the
musics are
a lot of faith on bruno here he's got to
be right about this because we're we're
basing a lot of this off our boy bruno
being like oh i found something and it's
like did you find something bruno are
you creating hysteria here
yeah yeah we're just relying a lot on
the technology of a teenage boy yeah
what ipad apps have been downloaded how
is he doing full scans of people's
genealogy
seriously
biometric genealogical scanning baby
yeah
he puts in all this technology he put
some where are his parents my boy put
some cardboard on amazon alexa and glued
some christmas lights to it and
everyone's like he's a genius
this guy's not inventing anything new
right he was like what if i change
alexa's name to zuzu
he got a gopro with a cord on it it was
like i made a security camera
it's like my guy this exists this will
impress uh kamala's dad so he'll let me
marry his daughter
crazy crazy anyway um but yeah no it is
very weird that uh bruno has all this
technology i don't know what's happening
with that i think he's uh in line uh
he's working with the ten rings actually
to uh they're funding him yeah i'm
giving him all the stuff um he's gonna
be in a he's gonna be in a cabin in the
woods before you know it making bombs
out of wood and sticks uh and berries
exactly we can't trust this guy at all
we can't trust him
you guys are being unnecessarily mean to
this core character
to be fair
that dance because bruno bryant
why why does disney just vilify people
named bruno this has been about bad i
know right this is like an epidemic of
bruno hatred oh my god
we're not allowed to talk about him now
like we have to call him brian we can't
even give him his name i'll never
forgive never not even once but yeah no
so like yeah this idea of being humans
being
mutants actually also makes sense in my
opinion because like fox is now part of
disney like we've been wanting disney to
buy foxes forever and now it's finally
happening like we're in we're living in
this new
mutant um era with disney and so like
now that like disney doesn't have to
compete with the mutants anymore it just
makes sense that you know the humans
they they try to make the inhumans which
you know is a brand that hasn't really
had the best reputation as of late
popular by association it's like hey if
we're cousins
then people will think we're cool
um so i think that this is the seeds
that marvel is planting with this reveal
it's like hey she's an inhuman but she's
also mutant because it's all labels
which is the importance of what kamala's
response was to the mutation thing it's
like it's just going to be another label
it all doesn't make sense
like it all doesn't matter it's like
it's all just
super powerful people at the end of the
day
i think disney's going to be different
disney's going to leave the mutants the
mutants and then they're going to retcon
and humans to be the disney princesses
and start yes the mirror verses exactly
what's this mirror burst game they're
trying to launch
exactly they're going to
and they're coming in it's like a it's
like a video game that's like a
multiverse disney type of game which
seems really cool but they're not fans
to talk about it we don't talk about
this game until they pay up okay yeah
we're getting paid okay sorry i just had
a question okay we're not no this game
give me the scratch and we'll talk about
the mirror verse okay yeah i know come
on disney give it a sweet green
um but but yeah and all in all what do
you guys think about this theory of
inhumans being mutants
starting with brandon um
rogus bogus or ogus i like where you're
at empty
but i still think
i i'm gonna call this one bogus okay
because okay i think i think marvel's
like we're done with inhumans we're
wiping them out baby
we gave you a black bolt we made his
brain into jelly and now we're done
goodbye humans hello mutants
that was symbolic of the death of the
humans they killed that bolt's brain
because i i thought years ago that they
would never ever bring the inhumans in
they made the tv show right didn't work
uh and put through them with miss marvel
they had me thinking like oh they're
gonna do it they're gonna bring in green
we saw the blue hands they're gonna do
it and then like
nope they're done they're done
[Music]
they're done they're done
so that's mine i say bogus
okay well okay i'll take the bogus all
right that makes a lot of sense though
what you think whitney honestly i'm only
the only reason i'm giving this an ogus
is because
mother i need a refresh on all of this
before i can make any decisions
i
i am not joking like i can barely keep
the comics versus the movies straight
when it comes to like pre-scroll [ __ ]
because it's so right it's very
different to everything and because i've
i've read and watched both i'm always
like wait what happened
when and where and why and then i also
am a person where like i didn't watch in
humans i'm sorry i never saw it so i
don't even know what we're losing by
losing the inhumans here so i'm just
like right i've only given it an ogus
cause i'm the wrong person to ask i
don't know
i don't
know i don't know no like no you're
you're you're completely right because
that's pressure course
the whole scroll conflict in the comics
are super complicated
[Applause]
the cree don't get along with anybody
they're always beefing with everybody
like the most like hot-headed race so it
is kind of confusing to like kind of
like it's that and then it's also the
science right where it's like i'm
confused the things that i'm confused
about are just in my own brain because
i'm a dummy where i'm like wait did that
happen in the comics or the movies i
can't remember but then also what tommy
was saying where it's like the science
of marvel like
is it consistent because i feel like i
know the rules and then they hit us with
this [ __ ] out of nowhere and all of a
sudden there's a zoo zoo taking
someone's biometrics and
23andme.com [ __ ] and it's like what
right so i need i need more information
right now like i need more information
than i actually have i feel dumb for
this answer but i'm kind of just no it's
it's honest somebody clarify all of this
please i need to know that
i mean no that's a totally fair answer
because like there's a lot about like
marvel has been around for so long and
so like there's a lot of just like
really intricate like weird science and
like cultural alien cultural stuff that
like
not everyone's gonna have knowledge with
like like on like right at the moment so
like i totally understand oh my god i
will take the yogas yeah ogus
for no reason other than me
no it's not it's not you it's just
marvel being complex really it's a lot
of [ __ ] oh
i work here and i need someone to make
me a video about this
can somebody volunteer on staff to make
a whitney make it for me i will i will
make that video i actually have a really
interesting theory as to what that uh
splinter cell is but anyway
give me that mr salvi uh well you know i
think the more we hear from kevin feige
uh
fikey
the illuminati was basically his way of
appeasing
fans
of things like casting john krasinski is
mr fantastic he's given a quote saying
that the fans really wanted that so they
thought that would be a nice touch i
think having anson mount come back as
black bolt was a similar thing so that
would make my my my rookie tuner go this
way but mt this is disney baby it's a
for-profit brand
the introduction of a new inhumans on a
disney plus show you got to be kidding
me i'm going rogues with this baby i
mean
look what they're doing daredevil's back
kingpin's back we've got jessica jones
getting a new name on the on the splash
title page aka jessica jones you know
what the i think where i think the
inhumans will be back and better than
ever baby i that and i think and i hope
so because that suit boy that black
bolts who look nice so i want to see
like a really good comics accurate in
humans in the mcu yeah i am really
excited though that jessica jones is
like now a canon disney princess because
yes
i think mulan gets blacked out on
whiskey she lived through a pretty nasty
war oh yeah oh yeah
she's got
yeah
yeah it's true war changes everyone uh
but up next brandon has got a really
interesting theory about a new possible
all father odin in the mcu but first be
sure to check out our new
rockstarsmerch.com website where it's
your last chance to grab our latest
obsession shirt cosmic daydream inspired
by the miss marvel series because miss
marvel has ended and so the shirt is
going back into the vault where uh only
the coolest of the cool can grab it
just kidding no one can grab it because
it's that's actually anywhere
um
and you can also grab our thor inspired
latest obsession shirt right now as well
don't miss out on these limited edition
merch options it's a great way to
support the channel and look fly in the
summer sun so check out all of our merch
options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com and we also want
to thank bluechu for sponsoring this
video boners they make the world go
around since the beginning of time just
kidding guys it's time to bring that
summer heat into the bedroom confidence
can take you far in life it can also
help in the bedroom especially when it
comes time to step up to the plate and
that's where blue chew comes in luchu is
a unique online service that delivers
the same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis but in chewable tablets and
at a fraction of the cost you can take
them anytime day or night so you can
plan ahead or be ready whenever an
opportunity arises the process is simple
sign up at bluetooth.com consult with
one of their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you'll receive
your prescription within days and the
best part it's all done online so no
visits to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations and no waiting in line at
the pharmacy bluetooth tablets are made
in the usa and prepared and shipped
direct to your door in a discreet
package it's time to get off the couch
back to work if your tool needs an
upgrade head to bluechew.com so if you
can benefit for some extra confidence
when it's time to perform luchu can help
and we've got a special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth free when you
use our promo code rogue at checkout
just pay five dollars shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code rogue to
receive your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank bluechu for sponsoring this
podcast and we also want to thank our
partners at athletic greens zak tommy
and brandon and other new rockstars team
members have started taking ag-1 every
day to improve their immune systems and
increase their daily energy they love
how conveniently it fits into their
daily routine as well as how great it
tastes one scoop of ag1 in just a cup of
water provides 75 high quality vitamins
minerals whole foods source superfoods
probiotics and adaptogens to help you
start your day right athletic greens
uses the best of the best ingredients
based on the latest science with
constant product iterations and
third-party testing and for every
purchase they donate to organizations
helping to get nutritious food to kids
in need including no kid hungry here in
the u.s
it's just one scoop of ag-1 in a cup of
water every day that's it no need for a
million different pills and supplements
to look out for your health so to make
it easy athletic greens is going to give
you a free one-year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
and all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com rogue again that is
athleticgreens.comrogue to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
we also want to thank ferrari for
sponsoring this video because summer is
here and whether you're spending long
sunny days by the pool or exploring new
places on vacation or even seeing how
many trips to the movie theater you can
make every week we're all striving to
make this the best summer ever and the
faraday brand makes clothes perfect for
the summer their collection of high
quality clothing is incredibly soft and
comfortable always sustainably minded
and meant to be worn from surf to city
to cineplex parody is a family-run brand
making high-quality timeless clothing
with modern design and functionality
they've mastered the art of the perfect
summer outfit you know what i mean
effortless but still looks good super
comfortable but designed with intention
the kind that looks like it might be
vintage but it fits so well that it
feels like it was just made yesterday
just for you that's what ferrari does
best obscure producer brandon loves his
ferry you'll find him spending all
summer running around disneyland in his
belt loop all day short yeah baby he
loves how comfortable they are as well
as how stylish he looks in them he looks
very stylish so stylish their clothes
are thoughtfully crafted with a classic
style and you'll wear them over and over
and over again verity is so committed to
sustainability they even have a lifetime
guarantee of quality they'll replace or
fix your clothes forever no matter what
literally
no matter what so your clothes can last
as long as your favorite summertime
memories and right now faraday is giving
all rogue theory fans 20 off let me say
that again
parody is giving rogue theory fans 20
offs if you head to
faritybrand.com rogue and use the code
rogue at checkout to get this deal that
is code rogue at ferrity f-a-h-e-r-t-y
brand dot com slash rogue for twenty
percent off faraday brand.com
rogue and for our second rogue theory
topic of today we're turning it to
off-screen producer brandon who has his
own unique rogue theory around four take
it away bran that's right here it is
folks get ready for this the next time
that we see our beautiful baby boy baby
boy thor he will no longer be thor he
will be odin himself my friends okay
and here's why
here's why okay
ragnarok has happened the beautiful
cycle of life and death for all as
guardians has occurred
asgard's gone well now it's new asgard
whatever uh freak is gone odin's dead
loki's dead hell is somewhere out there
all the warriors three are dead sif is
missing an arm but most everyone is dead
okay a lot of asgardians died true this
has happened so all of our players are
dead and it's time for the recycle to
reset but thor has not died okay he's
supposed to die it's part of ragnarok
too everyone's gotta die so people can
be reborn but he's selfish he wants to
live on he doesn't want to die or has he
died
has he died i think in thor love and
thunder we saw the death of our baby boy
thor the thor that we've known this
whole time he's grown he's matured he's
become worthy he has taken up the mantle
but then he
started ragnarok he let it happen and
the last thing that needed to happen for
our baby boy thor was to learn how to be
a true god and to love his people which
he did i think him sharing his magic
with the kids right we see him make that
beautiful like tree but all that magic
right it was gold it wasn't that was the
color of it which is like the odin force
color right gold is like odin's magic
and like his new armor is gold it has
all that infused all father energy
so i think now especially that he has a
kid he has his own thor to raise uh i
know her name is love and i know she's
different but like she's the new thor i
think uh and so i think the next time
that we see
uh thor he will be odin i think this has
i think this is the new cycle and it has
begun and he's now odin love is the new
thor and maybe he's gonna pop that fake
eye out and put his eye patch back on
yeah definitely
he's gonna have a big bushy beard i
think if if there's a thor five he'll
definitely be odin in that but maybe
even the next time we see thor
he'll be full on odin that's my my rogue
theory there
i love this a lot like i i did have a
similar thought in the past because like
i love this idea of there always being
like like they're being like a thor that
grows into an odin that becomes the next
odin that makes the next door like i
think that'd be an amazing cycle i
really hope that they're doing that in
the mcu i really love this theory
brandon i love it because i was thinking
like bore you know we never know
anything about bore who's like odin's
dad
yeah and like i think
i don't i don't know if this is true
enough but like when odin was like a
baby boy was he thor was he like the god
of thunder or was he always just like
odin son of bore and one day you'll be
the king or something like that i think
it was just the son of bore i think odin
actually
made
me near um like when he was king yeah
he was like we gotta we gotta make a
hammock
the dwarves gave him like this uh
special moon rock they were like oh
thanks and then he had to like stop like
this huge spirit of the storm so he
shoved it into the into the hammer so
that's why in the comics anyway um they
can use the power of thor because it's
like this ancient um storm
in the hammer so yeah anyway that's i
would like it to in history in my brain
if thor finds uh gungmir which is like
odin's big spear uh that has a ton of
power inside of it and can be used like
a bifrost if he finds it like flying out
in space somewhere uh and he gets that
and he starts wielding like molnier
mjolnir and gungner together and just
being like a badass like old man old man
thor yeah i think that's essentially
what was happening at the end of 41
thunder when he had the thunderbolts and
like that's why
the those kids had that different color
lightning yeah because he was wielding
both his blue power thor and now um the
zeus is golden power so if he finds that
uh that's that spear i feel like that
same thing would happen and he would
truly become uh like odin essentially
with that power because i don't think uh
uh
uh valkyrie
i thought she might become owed it but i
don't think that's going to happen she
doesn't seem to want to be no the leader
anymore right
no yeah she seems to just you know she
loves the her people but like she's just
more so about defending her people
um than anything really well and she's
indoctrinating these kids to become
valkyrie too she's uh
take my job
i'm gonna train these kids and that's
what you gotta watch out for whoever
starts training the kids you gotta watch
out for them because they're raising an
army yeah
that's right
i i love that theory i i want i will
basically i want more more of that
character so if we can transition
uh elevate him up to the status of odin
and keep him around for more for more
movies i'm in i also i agree i think
that's a really good point like him
relinquishing with i mean part of thor's
thing in the comics in the movies is his
ego and his like kind of bravado him
realizing he had to like give the kids
some of his power to like to win was
like it was an evolution for him as as a
person as a god as a character so i like
the idea that he kind of was like
you know the whole kind of
beginning of the movie was him doing
everything by himself and then being
like we did it as a team and then at the
end obviously the parallel or whatever
is that he realized he really did need a
team and instead of the guardians of the
galaxy he had uh you know mrs bechtold's
kindergarten class uh
it empowered into god's status so
yeah
i love that theory i think that that
makes a lot of sense and uh you know i
know the gold uh mt said that that could
be from zeus's
lightning bolt but i
i'm gonna go to choose that it was the
goal of another
another great god that got the goal of
voting as brandon said so
so i'm in i'm on board with that i i
like that theory i'm gonna i'm gonna
give this one also an ogus because i do
really like it
um but the only reason ogus is because
i think i agree more with the idea that
if there's like a thor five we'll see
him as odin because there's still the
hercules of it all right
[Music]
right so i think that the next time we
see thor obviously it's gonna be
fighting hercules and i do think that
that might be
his very last lesson he has to learn
about his ego um because this one was an
amazing great lesson he also had to let
go of jane foster yeah just powered his
kids like tommy said i can love that
answer perfect yes um but also in the
comics the thing that i'm most excited
to see with hercules is just
their dynamic from the comics was
basically we have the same powers and
the same strengths basically and they
are just constantly like locked in
battle and then they always become
friends at the end which is really fun
um so i am kind of excited to see them
develop that start from like uh i hate
you no i hate you well my dad said i
should hate you well my dad is dead like
i want to see that happen and then
develop into like a bromance yeah and i
want to see that happen before he goes
full okay so that's why my answer is is
ogus because i do agree i agree with all
of y'alls yes yes yes i just want this
to happen first
i would like if they start fighting and
thor's like losing and then all of a
sudden he's like oh my god why am i
falling asleep he just like starts going
into an odin sleep uh that's his
transition
[Laughter]
a really i didn't i didn't actually
think about that because like you're
right a whitney because like they're
they're definitely going like the the
hercules route and we're gonna see at
thor versus hercules showdown which i'm
very excited for
um so like i think thor five is going to
be that um you know hercules versus thor
and then maybe at 4-6 this is when you
know chris evans christopher sorry this
is when chris had like all right i'm all
floored out i'm like i need to move on
with my career so like i'm going to
become like the new odin and i'm going
to pass on stormbreaker to beta ray bell
which is like odin's role in uh the
comics he's like all right beta ray bill
you're not worthy of this hammer and so
i that'd be really great to see like an
odin thor pass on the hammer to vader
ray bill and be like yeah i'm new new
orleans why not um so yeah i i'm gonna
give that an ogus as well because i feel
like you know just like whitney said i
feel like it's the next time
he's probably still gonna be four but
the next time after that yeah i can see
the odin thing okay i'll take it
that was my i'm sorry i didn't give it
an official
my first time on the new format guys but
yes
no i'm gonna give it a little bit more
than uh a no guess it's like uh an og is
headed towards three yeah
it's okay
i'll take it
ogus rising
yes okay
yes
oh my god
all right so now guys it's time for our
rogue question you guys ready yes yes
yes yes chef
all right
now we've had our first official mcu
mutant identified as one kamala khan aka
miss marvel who is your rogues pick for
the second official mutant in the mcu
i'm gonna give you a good one and this
is the one i want and you probably
already know what it is empty there's
gonna be a scene uh in she-hulk uh and
she's gonna be hanging out uh in our
in a bar
you know drinking with her friend
commiserating about her life as a lawyer
but this bar has arcade machines in the
back uh and you're gonna hear like that
dumb machine ain't my quarter and you're
gonna off screen see a little a little
blast of light and you pan over and done
had to suffer bring her back give her
her plasmoids let her let her reign for
a thousand years you're an actual
character in a live action movie for two
months for fun
jubilee for brandon i love it
it's all about jubilee
it's all about dribbling she's always
been the coolest expert for me like
she's so she's a nerd and she's just
super dope and like i i want her in the
mall in the marbles personally because i
think she'd be great she's going to be
in every film yes eric like she needs to
be the new uh stan lee yes jubilee
appear playing video games in the
background of every film that'd be
hilarious uh but what about you whitney
okay
i'm gonna go rogue and i'm gonna say
that
i think that the next x-men introduced
into not just the mcu but the disney
family as a whole
is that frozen three
is gonna be co-starring
rogue herself and elsa and rogue are
going to have to team up and go glove
shopping
[Music]
very specific problems and then if all
lgbtqia plus character bobby drake goes
you know what i should be jealous but
i'm not anymore because i'm not
interested
i found an ice archway for them to kiss
under
um hell yeah hey
i don't know um how you guys got access
to my fan fiction diary but uh you can
share that on the show that'd be great
just kidding no this is i love that idea
of uh i really like uh because elsa i
always joke that elsa is like a
superhero and a mutant oh sam i'm always
like elsa and roger basically the same
character with just like they just
changed little things here and there
basically yeah
basically um so yeah i do love that a
lot
they gotta go glove shopping girls
gloves gay girls glove shopping that's
what i want to see
pivot away from gay girls glove shopping
slightly to
back to how dare you back to marvel
she-hulk where i think that our our hero
uh lawyer will need to
um interview uh
an expert you know often in in court
cases they need an expert to come in and
explain the science or something behind
it and this could be someone with a
mutation that they've been able to you
know relatively hide or hasn't raised a
lot of eyebrows or you know
and
in their earliest form in the comics
they were simply a human looking person
who actually played college football
because of their mutation and that's dr
hank mccoy
dr hank mccoy who uh in his earliest
iteration just had huge hands and feet
and and animal
strength and speed but wasn't to the
naked eye other than his hands and feet
which you know
your common football basketball baseball
they all like usually one characteristic
of a professional athlete is they have
huge hands like guys just like pitchers
and baseball have longer fingers
whatever i think she'll go to dr hank
mccoy in a non-blue beast form uh for an
opinion right and then we'll get that
little ban in it stinger again
and it's all starting to come together
beautiful i hope they do that every time
but they gotta do it
i hope that that's just like what the
signal from
right
but no i do love that a lot because like
i feel the x-men 97 cartoons started off
with a beast being arrested yeah and all
that stuff so i feel like beast being an
introductory character makes sense of
course like you said with the um you
know he's he's an expert on mutant
physiology much like professor xavier is
saying and i feel like it'd be a really
interesting way to introduce you like
your non xaviers your non-magnetos like
you're you're you're really crucial
x-men type characters yeah first and
then just like leading up to your like
big magneto and yeah xavier revealed so
yeah i love that a lot and i actually
think i'm going to give you the rogue
question winning points of the day
because that's just really funny what a
comeback story what a deserving win by
me who has not inconvenienced
anyone
all right yeah
you deserve the weird topic you're a
smart boy but you guys are all smart all
right um and i love you guys so much
like i say at the end of every episode
because this is the end of the episode
that's it for this episode
thanks for our amazing guests whitney
van lenningham tommy bechto an
off-screen producer brandon support all
of their stuff all of them on twitter
they're amazing people and you can
support our channel by checking out all
of our awesome merch over at
newrockstarsmerch.com and of course if
you want to continue the conversation
head on over to our discord just make
sure you're over 18 and you can just
search for new rockstars and discord and
join us there because we're talking
about a lot of interesting stuff follow
me at mastertainment follow new
rockstars and all social platforms and
subscribe to our channel here on youtube
and we love you guys so much thank you
for spending time with us we always
always appreciate it we appreciate you
and just be safe and good to each other
all right goodbye
[Music]
you